this is really exciting you know there's
there's that saying um
you've got friends that you can not see
for several years
and then when you catch up with them it
just feels like you never lost a step
would you say that that's kind of what
your relationship is like
with these two characters oh for me it
is for sure
um you know unfortunately because of the
the pandemic we couldn't work together
this uh
on on the series but we're so in tune
with each other we kind of
you know know how to play with each
other even if we're not in the same room
so it was a thrill to be able to get a
chance to
to beat mike and sully again
even though i was just mike right
when it came out of my mouth i went no
i'm not bothered yeah
john what what keeps you coming back
what keeps you coming back to these guys
uh just the imagination of pixar um
they're just brilliant they're great
great storytellers and they create these
alternate worlds with uh you wanna you
wanna visit and live with
uh the people you just
the characters the monsters you kind of
just fall in love with and you want to
know what's going to happen
and this you know i was i think it was
in high school
when the first one came out something
like that it was a while ago
and i remember thinking to myself like
i'll be so great to see how the business
continues
in this new way and so many years later
we're finally finding that out
did either of you you know in your
downtime when you were thinking about
these characters on your own did you
ever think
ah i wonder how they would do this
well you know i i didn't really because
uh until they said we're thinking about
doing this
now the second movie was a prequel so
that's what they were younger
so there was you know this whole world
like well what happened then you know
for the first movie
so uh the trilogy of them is kind of
great so this
this just continues from where the the
first movie ended
it's the next day which i thought was a
great idea
and the setup of you know young tyler
coming
thinking he's going to be a scarer then
finding no
he's got to learn how to be funny wasn't
there's your story there's you know they
just sit
in a in a beautiful plot like right away
and then now mike and sully are managing
the laugh floor
a little out of their element and it
gives us a lot of chance to
to meet new characters great new
characters great new cast
and it was it's really exciting
you guys talk about the magic of pixar
and that's definitely a real
thing and in the years since the first
monsters inc it's just become
massive right it's an event whenever a
new pixar product
is out but when you think back to the
time that you you guys were doing
the first monsters inc did you have an
inkling that it was going to be
as big and as special and as memorable
as it has been
i just thought it was going to be good
oh
big big and that's out of my realm
i just think that pixar's they've got
such great tastes and they know how to
incorporate like
all ages into their audience uh
they're great storytellers and the first
movie
when i i saw it all alone in a theater
at
on a lot and i just was
you know going from a dark booth you
know where you
do this and you hope it and you don't
see anything and then
two years later there's this magnificent
palette of characters and imagination
and and
it was so stunning i i just i really
couldn't get out of my seat for about 20
minutes afterwards
going wow what a gift to be a part of
this world and um of and
to work for these kind of geniuses it's
a
it's an honor it's been a favorite
world yeah yeah it's been a favorite in
so many households including including
my own so it's
it's special to see this coming back um
something else that i'm a big fan of i
really like though john is uh
is the righteous gemstones uh i was
wondering if they had a chance to work
with eric andre
jason schwartzman eric roberts yet for
season
eric two roberts i've worked with a lot
eric andre
uh one day i saw him the other day uh i
got to work with him one day
um but yeah i'm neck deep in that right
now
yeah it's really exciting stuff well
gentlemen again thank you so much you
know
my uh i was just talking with my son and
daughter about how this series is coming
out because it was
a big favorite of theirs when when they
were really really young and i'm excited
to watch this
and re-explore it with them again
all right well i was just going to say
before you go this is i'm glad you can
watch it with them but you know
the show is the family can sit and watch
it together
and um you know i think that's a real
gift
absolutely all right cheers gentlemen
thank you
you